do you have a cheat drawer in the house
because I feel like I'm I don't know I
like do you tell you something that's
going to upset you okay
Jennifer just eats whatever she wants
and whatever she wants Pizza cookies ice
cream everything is it the working out
she works out I mean I work out too
I don't magically appear to be 20 years
old you know what I mean with perfect
skin and the whole I'm she is a just uh
there's no taking away the work ethic
the work ethic is real the discipline is
very real but also the Superhuman thing
is real she says the most gorgeous woman
in the world she looks spectacular
no I'm swooning this is this is me
living vicariously through romance and
Men appreciating women and all of it
okay by the way I'm back here we go
she's an easy person appreciative will
you play a game with me called the final
five yes
okay number one what is a random pet
peeve that drives you nuts people who
want to get paid for doing nothing
well I'm
I'm for everyone to get to get paid for
every
everything are doing so yeah
okay number two what's a life moment
that you want to relive again and again
I guess I would Center the the question
around you know there's so many things
my kids the birth of my children you
know all the things that I've done you
know with my kids as a it's just the joy
of life you know it's um it's the heart
of life and you know these beautiful
children who are innocent and loving and
who want to you know who sit in your lap
it holds you into you know and then they
eventually turn into like you can close
the door
oh yeah so you don't want to play Shoots
and Ladders I can I can just go okay
um it's it's the it's the gift of Life
all those moments and that that I'm
beginning to see now how they are
fleeting but now I just like I treasure
all these little moments I just went and
looked at colleges with my daughter and
it was uh it was like all these ones I
showed Goodwill Hunting to my middle
child and like that was the best
experiences of my life yes
I love those moments so much as a parent
I know exactly what you're talking about
okay it's number three if we asked um
your beautiful wife
um you're a goddess of a wife today if
there was one thing she could change
about you what would it be just today
like uh she would probably want to
cultivate brevity in my uh
the way I speak you know I tend to go I
don't know if you've noticed but I go on
and on and on and on and on talk I talk
a lot and I love talking circles and I
think she's never said that to me but
that would be my guess okay number four
when was the last time you went skinny
dipping
this is going to turn into a different
kind of story my wife and I went on a
went on a little vacation recently we
went like in the pool I don't know if
that counts as skinny dipping it was
well were you naked the 80s College
movie or anything it was just kind of
like were you naked that skinny dipping
they were naked in the pool
thank you
[Applause]
it's nothing more beautiful than
swimming in that birthday suit okay
final question if there was one film
that you could remake anyone in history
something that's personal to you or that
you've always loved what would it be
now that's a hard question because like
I wouldn't remake all the movies I love
because they were made by my heroes and
they're brilliant and they should be
left just as they are yeah
I do not disagree with that answer and
that's spoken like a true filmmaker
[Music]
foreign